hi everybody and welcome my name is
Damien McLennan I'm Damien M on Twitter
I'm the CTO of a company called work 180
but I'll talk a bit more about that in a
moment
firstly I'd like to actually just thank
all the organizers and crew here at NDC
massive job putting something like this
together and it's easier to take it for
granted so I think I've done an amazing
job I've been to all all of the Sydney
ones now and it's awesome this is my
first time speaking here though - thank
you to everybody for coming in over
whelming actually there's so many good
talks to choose from so I really
appreciate them everyone coming in
though on the topic lot of people in the
room I'm just like gage a bit of
experience he's using donate core
everyone excellent who's using it with
docker half the people excellent
cool because I sort of struggled a
little bit with you know how much don't
Nicole are doing how much docker to do
so it'll be interesting so today but I
feel I'm going to tell you a little bit
of a story and it's it's something a bit
different to a talk that I would
normally give where I'm you know the
expert in something we're trying to be
the expert in something this is a story
about a journey that I've been on with
with the new tech stack spoiler it's
done in curtain docker and and what I've
learned and there's some code into but
it's basically a story that's not done
yet this is my journey this is my field
notes so basically this story I'm
somebody with a lot of experience
writing code and shipping code and
architecting code and deploying code and
I've got some pretty strong opinions
about what what good looks like and
whisky and yes I've got some strong
opinions on you know what I think good
looks like and and then this year I sort
of got back on to writing a lot of code
after you know a two-year stint of
management hell and so when I got back
to that the whole sort of tech world had
changed underneath me
and I'm sorry to make a whole bunch of
technical choices you know and you know
being the first technical person in a
startup and a lot of my go-to patterns
on this new
just didn't work you know the way I know
how to do stuff had all changed and I
felt like I was sort of treading a whole
bunch of ground new ground and so today
this talk is sort of my journey and some
of the decisions I had to made and how I
got there and I'm not claiming to be the
expert in this and it's not the perfect
solution it is a journey that's why it's
called you know my field notes my friend
Vanessa here said yesterday and a
completely unrelated conversation
there's really no value in just hello
world demos all the time and there's no
value in just pure success stories and
that's sort of the gist of my talk it's
you know this is this is where I've gone
in in the hope that some of my learnings
you know give you some ideas save you
some time or whatever else maybe some
different ways of looking at stuff and
we are just before lunch and we probably
won't have lots of time for QA which is
probably good because it might put me on
the spot but this is something that I've
learned through talking to a lot of
people and whatever so I would love if
you have different experience or more
experience or some questions I would
love over the next day and a half people
to grab me and chat through this stuff
because I'm really interested in in
learning about better ways to do stuff
and I think we can all get better it's a
bit more background I've been around for
a while I'm starting to feel like the
the grumpy old guy in the industry
that's kind of seen it all before and
all the cycles happen again I cringed a
little bit yesterday in the keynote when
Dylan Beatty said I'm really old I was
born in 1978 and I beat you mate
and I've been doing what a lot of people
called sort of DevOps since well before
it was cool yeah I think I started doing
CI
in about 2003 and a lot of deployment
automation then when it was a fairly out
there thing to do
and that's been a lot of time doing
consulting work for ratifies ready for
people intervention work to ratify for a
lot of years and and the team of people
around around me and Brisbane we did a
lot of rescue projects essentially where
it was getting everything's on fire and
we'd have to get in to solve problems
and have some very difficult
conversations where people wanted
guarantees and you know if anyone's done
a lot of consulting when someone says I
want to guarantee that that's going to
be fixed in your life
we can't have it but what we got very
good at a mitigation for that was we got
very very good at iterating very very
quickly so we can say look we're not
gonna promise stuff but you can track
our progress from literally day one so
we've got very very good at automating
our deployments cuz that's the best way
to actually show progress is getting
something to production and making a
little bit better every day and getting
those runs on the board so we all got
very very good at writing deployment
scripts and and to ship code and so
every one of the consultants you know
around our team would have their own
Dropbox folder full of PowerShell
scripts and and whatever else to to ship
code and it was on one of those projects
that that octopus deploy was born
everyone used octopus in here
most of people a lot of people it's
anyone from octopus X octopus octopus so
and that's yeah one of these projects on
a ratify project is where octopus was
born to basically pull stovall we're
sitting around at lunch one day he's
like this is a self problem that we do
this time and time and time again
there's got to be a product that that
can sort of follow these common patterns
and we know to work and so he left and
started that that company built that
product so I worked with Paul at octopus
for a while I mean in the early days
sort of building some up some the early
team and engineering practices and then
at the beginning of 2016 I took a bit of
a break from that and took on like I
said management hell an engineering
management role in a you know sort of
big company agile transformation that
sort of needed some technical leadership
so I walked away from octopus then so
anyway after you know my experience I
have opinions I thought that would get
more of a laugh out of Europe and it
also turns out that the big companies
trying to do a transformation at the
same time as as a merger where they're
the smaller fish big opinions don't
always fly so I had to leave that so at
the beginning of this year that's all
that preamble was to get to sort of this
year I joined a company called work 180
I'm not gonna go into the full picture
on work 180 I'm essentially it's a it's
a job sport for women and I'm more than
happy to come and talk at great length
about that we can talk to Lorraine my
awesome colleague down here about it as
well and it's a company that was started
by some some friends of mine a few years
ago and they built they build a business
and prove this business on a third party
SAS job platform and it got to the point
where the idea is for in the
international scale and things we wanted
to do sort of outgrew that platform so
it came time to build build our own our
own platform that we could iterate on
and so that's that's where I came into
this company so I needed to make some
some tech choices and I had the fun
process of completely green slate no one
telling me what to do
which is which is awesomely fun and also
very very daunting I'm choosing a tech
stack so I had a few criteria it needed
to be unproductive for me mainly at
first but also then as I hired people
something that I could take my
experience and you know bring people on
and get them up to speed had to be
performing enough performance one of
those things that yeah had to be it had
to be performing enough I didn't want to
have you know a thousand server
instances for a hundred users that would
be that would be not performant enough
it all set to be somewhat investor
friendly you know we have taken on some
funding to expand over season and sort
of as I got in in the early days of
having having conversations with with
VCS and investors and some of them would
say hey look you know what's your tech
stack and in that kind of startup
investment world if you go dotnet on
Windows they go who the hell are you so
yeah it had to be had to be somewhat
sellable it had to be something that I
could hire for as well so yeah there's
sort of investor part plus the ability
to hire outside I met Paul of normal
people you know I love all the brisbane
ratify an octopus deploy people would
have worked with them all four years
uh-huh I wanted to work with some new
people which I did it's been wonderful
so I sort of didn't want to go with the
sort of normal thing that I know and you
know also the investor thing I didn't
want to go and fire up an enterprise
windows stack and it's also not super
cheap to run you know Windows instances
compared to it to Linux ones so I
considered a few things I considered
Python I'd been doing a little bit of
Python doing some sort of data
manipulation I like Python but I didn't
really love the idea of trying to run
that on a on a server-side process to
you know
web requests I didn't relate the
performance aspects of that same goes
for Ruby
that's probably my thousand server
instances for a hundred years
also I'm completely uncomfortable in
Ruby land note I considered pretty
seriously also considered go but I
didn't know anything about go and and I
don't know any NGO developers in
Brisbane so that was tricky considered
something on the JVM I knew some people
that was having a lot of success with
with Kotlin server-side Kotlin and that
looked cool but I knew that was gonna be
a pretty big learning curve on the JVM
just cradles a big curve whose Gradle so
yeah ultimately like dotnet caught it
has great performance metrics I could
say dotnet core on Linux and docker and
people go okay that sounds cool
and it was familiar enough that you know
I knew that there would be a bit of a
learning but I could I could get into it
and you know I knew that I knew c-sharp
really really well and I could teach
that so I ended up with dr. Cole and
docker that was obvious we're a startup
you have to use docker it's the future
Linux from a cost point of view made a
lot of sense
Postgres made a lot of sense as well I
didn't you know again want to be paying
for sequel server licenses and my
critique war I have opinions about my
sequel also consider document databases
I probably won't get a chance to talk
about that today but come and talk to me
about document databases so yeah
Postgres made a lot of sense
it's fast it's ridiculously stable it's
pretty battle tested AWS I've used the
yellow cloud and the blue cloud both
quite extensively and sorry to my
Microsoft friends and had this chat
yesterday I find the yellow one a little
bit more stable and predictable
that's all I'm gonna say about that also
knew that I didn't want to manage
infrastructure by hand and I'd play a
little bit with terraform and you enough
to be dangerous I still know enough to
be dangerous and also I thought while
I'm at it I'll throw away windows that
sort of slowly been moving away from
windows and decided to go all in on the
Mac and I knew that meant giving up my
beloved resharper shortcuts and yes I
know about Ryder but I decided to go
with V s code because it's amazing the
iteration on that product is really cool
haven't mentioned anything about front
in here that's one of the things that I
have fewer opinions about and I decided
to wait till I could hire somebody that
knew more about that it had had done
more opinions so I was Lorraine and so
we ended up with some with react I
figured it would be react or view I do
have opinions about angular and so we've
ended up with a combination of some asp
net MVC a lot of server-side stuff with
with react components and some other
react server-side i've react single page
apps as well so feeling like a beginner
again so at this point I've basically
been away from code for two years has
anyone taken a break from writing code
sort of in a you know management stint
and then going back in few yeah it's
hard it's really hard and you know after
two I feel like an absolute beginner
again and firstly because I was rusty
and that sort of comes about quickly but
also everything had changed everything I
knew had changed Donaire core you know I
understood the c-sharp but there was
enough sort of changes to the you know
the MVC stack and you know the whole
build pipeline or whatever the build
system in the runtime and it were a
little changed and and then I realized
every single thing that I knew about
building and deploying software with
this toolset that I had picked was
completely out the window and that's a
frightening place to be if anyone's kind
of being that no it's a really
frightening place to be it reminds me of
and again showing my age when dotnet
happened sort of going from classic ASP
and VB
six and it's like what is this whole new
world of what is a click event on a web
button for but heaps of fun and and
really really liberating and I have to
say that I have really rediscovered a
joy of writing code this year and as
sort of as you progress through your
career you kind of get to this point
where like I used to do that I've had so
much fun writing code this year it's
been great but what I didn't realize
that that pretty much everyone that was
that was talking going to use a group
talks and talking about dotnet core and
talking about docker and writing blogs
about it um they really weren't getting
past this and I don't know if it's just
a dot net community thing but we seem to
have this real thing of like wanting to
jump on the next bandwagon and it's like
you know asp net MVC core 2.1 comes out
and all the hello world talks get
wheeled out again and it's this really
frustrating thing that I've noticed in
the dotnet community I don't know if it
happens in other communities if anyone's
got some some thoughts on that and happy
to hear them but it seems to be this
real dotnet thing and you know one sort
of ever really goes further and part of
its the the user group format like it is
hard to get across a complex idea in a
40-minute session I get that one
exception though and have to give a
massive shout out and and I wish he
comes to I wish he would come to Sydney
at some point to a conference so I could
buy him a beer Andrew Locke it's anyone
heard of Andrew Locke or read his blog
fantastic so many times I'd be googling
like how do I do this and I'd come
across and relax blog which is at Andrew
Luck net and and save me so much time so
if you are getting into this go have a
look at that he's just released a book
that you know go by that fantastic
resource his website so what I had to
figure out dotnet core and and some of
the newer patterns you know how to do
configuration logging application
structure how did it build how to do
testing how did his CI how to build
container images how to host container
images how to deploy them how to manage
the infrastructure and and and again
remember with all these things I have
lots of experience in doing this in
other ways and
and you know so you know I could figure
out how to build and but then I had a
you know once I could get a container in
which I had to get it online somewhere
and then you know it's like okay tanner
orchestration it was just all of a
sudden I'm the dog doing I have no idea
what I'm doing and anyway that's kind of
there's a lot of preamble oh I get that
but that's sort of you know the journey
and and I sort of want to talk through
some of the details and some of the
stuff I've learned and again this
there's things in there that are not
finished so this is I'm kind of baring
my soul a little bit too so yeah please
come talk to me later if you've got
ideas and we can all learn from it so
yeah the first thing now here's what I
have to break the whole presenter mode
thing and up where's my beers code gone
most my mouth gone
I think it's time to do the mirror this
stuff
cool so one of the things that seems to
be Phil that's terrible how do we zoom
this sorry sorry
the lighting
little bit better yes it seems to be a
fairly fair amount of consistency around
how we structure the actual app itself
you know everyone sort of seems to agree
that you can have a source directory and
in that you've got you your application
code and then you can have a test
directory that seems to be fairly
consistent now there's probably nothing
too groundbreaking in here a couple of
things I like to do who uses Autofac
most of you excellent who use sort of
conventional registration of stuff yeah
cool
so it's something I really like to do is
it's basically in your auto effect
startups they look register assembly
modules and then you can just drop a
module in and put some conventions in
and it saves you a whole bunch of just
remembering to wire stuff up so a lot of
conventional based stuff something I've
always felt was I always hated code that
reached into configuration all the times
always like to sort of wrap wrap that in
something that you could inject does
everyone do that yeah some people know
but Nick or made that a little bit
tricky I sort of had to inject its
configuration into your configuration
thing and I'm still I'm still not 100%
happy with with how we're doing this I
don't like shipping lots of
configuration files with secrets in it I
don't like that at all I liked the
octopus way of doing things where you
had your web config with a key value
store and you could ask for a key value
and so you're your source repo doesn't
have all the config for all the
different environments but that sort of
goes against the grain with docker
because you want us to build that image
and ship it and so yeah you can use
environment variables there and that's
not it not really ideal either so
something I always like to do most of my
presentation
there it is
something I've always liked is does
anyone seem config injector commander
Harcourt from the Brisbane crowd have so
basically the ability to define a set in
class and register them always the
container and push them all in and it's
a really nice pattern because what it
will do is it will look through your web
config file in a sort of traditional
dotnet world it will scan through that
and will scan through all of your
settings and if you don't have a set in
class for a particular configure in the
config file it will blow up at startup
so it stops people from sneaking in
weird configuration things you don't
know about and it will also say if I'm
expecting a setting to be there and it's
not in the config it blows up on startup
so it makes your app really really
predictable and and that's a really
really nice pattern and I've sort of not
found the real equivalent of that yet
with dotnet core because we've got this
awesome thing where we can have you know
a lot richer object model in our
configuration but that doesn't really
fit with the just inject a single
setting so I know Andrews been working
on on a way to do that a little bit
better and that's probably something I'm
going to work with him on or so that you
can take it at pendency on a setting and
that setting might be a rich class so
this is something that I'm still not a
hundred percent happy with so at the
moment I'm sort of going with this
this configuration model and that could
be a string or it could be something
richer that you can deserialize out of
out of the the Jason one of the nice
things though is once we do get into
container land I can use environment
variables to override you know write
down into there but again that gets
really really ugly I've you know spoken
to people doing this stuff and they have
these deployment databases that
basically have all their configuration
settings like down all these levels and
they're basically writing out you know
250 environment variables when they
deploy a container and that can get
really really hideous as well so I don't
think this is a really self problem yet
so that's kind of on my on my list of
ugliness and yeah anyone solve that in a
really really nice way you have cool
come and tell me about it so yeah and
I've got I've got some thoughts on that
but yeah I would love to have
- about this because I was sort of after
going through this exercise of putting
this talk together I actually would like
to work on I'm sort of publishing some
stuff on github of you know here's how I
think this could work so this is like I
said it's part of my journey
so yeah configuration management the
other thing that I like to do is Sarah
log and seek is everyone using Sarah log
and seek okay so everyone else in the
room needs to use Sarah log and seek so
seek is a a logging server structured
logging server written by some a good
friends and ones over here again the
Brisbane mafia is coming for everyone so
Sarah log lets you write structured logs
so structured logs are not just a string
that you know you have to go and find
all the strings in your log files and
and grep through them all it actually
creates a message templates and then
puts data in there which lets you be
able to go on and query that and filter
it really really well so Sarah log does
that and then it has this really nice
thing that says let you read it's it's
builder out of configuration so in my
configuration I can say hey Sarah log
right to seek this the server name and I
can put an API key on there and and when
I run stuff up it pushes it into there
this is an amazing tool for debugging
your code in production there's one of
the things that once you are in docker
you know who still like IDPs onto our
web server and you know searches through
log files to find out what went wrong
you know on a Tuesday morning when your
customers are complaining at you yeah in
a docker world that's even harder
because then you've got all of a sudden
like SSH into the box and you know then
grep through it and you know like if you
can even get into it in the first place
and finding like it's all very ephemeral
you don't really want to go and you know
shell into your running containers to
find logs and and see makes that super
duper easy so that's a plug
yeah but it lets you really drill down
into into some finer detail that I don't
have because I spun that up actually
that's probably worth mentioning now
seek one of a great gentle introduction
to docker has started to use a few dev
dependencies so that's running in in
docker now so that was sort of how I got
into into doing this like well I want to
use Postgres so let me go and find a
container for that and I want to use
seek so you start to get a feel for for
docker if you're not using it yet by
just pulling a lot of the dev
dependencies which is great you know if
you are a consultant or work on a lot of
different stuff I sort of used to have
you know repave a laptop and and all of
a sudden I'd have you know MongoDB on
there and I might have couch on there
and I might have read us on there and I
might have you know all these different
runtimes and I might use two of them for
one project and another two for a
different project and this way you know
you can just kind of go bring up that
stack turn down that stack when you go
and work on the next project so docker
for your runtimes is fantastic so the
next thing that I had to figure out was
how to build them so again you see a lot
of these demos and it's you know don't
never still done a build and that's all
well and good but in pretty much no
instance in my professional career was
was that what it took to build it you
know you might have to bundle assets you
might have to setup versioning you might
have to do all these things you might
have to do some extra packaging build
library whatever it is as part of your
build it's very very rare that you have
a production build that is just run the
compiler like that's one step and so
through my career I've used all sorts of
different ways of orchestrating that you
know I've used an aunt who remember the
N and a few other people in and sake
which is PowerShell make that was fun
I've done horrible things with MS build
everything with a Miss fields a bit
horrible and I you know I've even gone
down the path of orchestrating the whole
thing you know in a CI so ever late team
city where you've got yes you have a
compile step you've got ten other steps
as part of your build chain in team city
which is all well and good until you
lose your team city instance and then I
go how did I build that software better
experience in the room so my favorite
one and it has stood the test of time
for a couple of years cakes anyone think
cake cake is wonderful so cake is is
c-sharp make we're very creative bunch
in this industry
cake is a build orchestration language
DSL essentially built in c-sharp which
is really wonderful because if you are
writing code in c-sharp it's it's far
less of a mental shift to go on and
write your your build code in c-sharp
than it is to jump into Ruby or XML or
PowerShell does anyone fine with
PowerShell that if you're writing it
every day it's easy and you skip one day
of PowerShell all gone you know it's
like working out with kettlebells you
can do that all the time and you take a
few days off and you pick it up again
the next day you can't walk that's
powers you're like one day off
PowerShell and just forget all of it you
know and I worked for a company that
basically did PowerShell all day long
so yeah cake is is wonderful so you can
specify targets and when you run this
target you have all these dependent
targets so I can have a build target and
a clean target and a publish target and
stuff like that so I can orchestrate my
build and I know that that will work all
the time so if you're not playing with
cake yet even in on sort of traditional
yet totally recommend that one it's it's
a really good consistent way to build
software and run software
just just selling you on tools today I
know so the next thing is building a
container image so again this was you
know I'm used to in in in the world that
I had lived in before as part of my cake
build the end of it it would it would
bundle everything up and it would call
you know new parkour when you get or
something like that and zip stuff up and
there'd be my version died of fact and I
could push that into octopus deploy or
something like that and you take that
artifact and drop it on a server and and
you know sort of deploying apps to
service with something on you really
really well and again all of that's
change you sort of now you're shipping
your entire runtime and that makes a lot
of sense because you know I'm sure a
bunch of you working a big enterprise
where some team wants to upgrade some
new version of something and everyone
freaks out because you know you've got
some incompatible version of the runtime
on a box and it's like I'm all of a
sudden you're going to need three weeks
of regression testing to be allowed to
do it you know point upgrade to fix a
critical bug anyone doctor is wonderful
for that because you can ship your
entire runtime and it makes upgrades
really easy because I think that I can
upgrade that project and put it there
and it's just going to be completely
isolated as a process from something
else
so that's great but then it comes to
building it so you know again going back
to my the way I used to do it it would
sort of make sense you could build your
code and publish the code and then take
those artifacts and push it into docker
but that sort of then loses the build
isolation as well so where doc is
fantastic is I can have my build
environment in a container which is
awesome because again you know if you've
been in an environment where somebody
wants to build something with a
different version of a runtime and all
of a sudden you know you're ten build
agents have some incompatible thing and
you've got to make sure you get the
right build agent or upgrade them all at
once and all of a sudden you're not
allowed to upgrade something because you
build agents aren't compatible evenly
lived that fun dream yep we're Sam I
know I saw him in a minute ago someone
had to manage that full-time so yeah
building in a container is is wonderful
and there's a couple of ways to do that
I found as well so as I started to look
into it I found that in in some
different environment like the Ruby
world they would sort of build lots of
containers they would have a container
where they configured it to run a set of
unit tests another container where they
would run you know some integration
tests or whatever and so as part of
their build process that's been up lots
and lots of containers which completely
freaks me out
actually because I'm sort of from that
you build your artifact once and so that
was sort of really really weird to me
and where I ended up was building and
testing in a container now there was
lots of docker experience in here as
well so anyone using multistage builds
yep lots of nods a few hands yeah so for
those who don't know docker has is this
great thing called a multi-stage build
where you can basically specify a
container image that has all of your
build runtimes and SDKs and stuff like
that that it takes to build stuff and
then you can take the artifact out of
that container and push it into the next
container and that works really really
nicely actually I should go back just
quickly to to look at the output of cake
gee that's awful isn't it bigger
so if I run my build shell script it
will call into it or bootstrap
everything and run all these targets in
cake and it and it does all the stuff it
cleans out although being an object
folders and it default MVC template has
a whole bunch of just mismatched
versions of things which is good time
yes a cake will clear out folders and
I've got to publish like a disk folder
where I can push my publish stuff into
so it sort of cleans it out because it's
always fine when you make some upgrade
and you build but you've got something
sitting in your object older and it you
know behaves weirdly so that's that's
the output of my of my cake build there
which is cool so anyway then the next
thing that I had to figure out was was
getting that into that that docker file
so and again I stole a lot of this I
think originally from Andrew Locke so
it's really R is a good place to go and
find some of that stuff but yeah I can I
can specify this this dotnet SDK image
that has you know everything under the
Sun in it and then I can install node on
it and then throw that away to do you
know any kind of asset packaging and
stuff like that and then I just
basically copy all the files in and then
run my run my build so it's really
really consistent and then I can take
the output of that that I put in my
discolor and copy it into a new
container that's based off this runtime
image and if I were to run that
Sydney I'm saying hey look do it do a
docker build in this directory so to
find the docker file tagging in DC
Sydney if I could spell NDC Sydney and
you know that's I've run that earlier
today so it's pretty quick I'm so doc
acacia every file system layer and now
it's getting in and running my cake
stuff inside the container
cool so now if I were to go into a
docker image I have a lot yeah I can see
I've got a I've got my builder image
that's you know - a gig of stuff and
then my run tiny runtime image which is
a whole bunch smaller so that makes it
easier to you know I'm shipping I'm
pushing smaller images around to servers
so that's gonna make my my um
initialization time a lot faster and it
sort of reduces my surface attack area
if you know anyone were to try to get
into that container because I'm not you
know shipping node don't mean to throw
shade it no it's just so what I have
lost with this what I have lost is in my
nice old safe team city world I'd have a
build and I could say all the tests pass
and I could drill down into that and
it's all really wonderful in my new
world I get this and that's not as
comforting although I do have a few
tests and that's something that I've
sort of you know like missing in this
new world and so there's a few solutions
one is I could take the the test
artifacts out of that the test reports
and got and pushing them into something
and you know surface a dashboard of them
but certainly it's something that
doesn't have that nice a nice overview
of it again if someone's got a beautiful
solution to that would love to hear it
so I can build a container on my image
so I can build a container image on my
local machine that's wonderful that's
also completely useless to me as a you
know professional so then I started to
dive into the world of CI and so you
know team city has always been wonderful
to me we get on very very well but it
sort of didn't feel like the right tool
for this and also you know while I'm in
the mode of I'm gonna throw out
everything I know and start again from
scratch a friend of mine who I am still
friends with recommended that I start
playing with Jenkins
and Jenkins incredible powerful and and
the selling point was that was that you
can have a Jenkins file and you put that
in your repo and and it will watch your
github organization and when you push in
your repo to go there's a repo I can see
a Jenkins file in there and just build
up your stuff from convention so that's
one of the things that I was going to
mention around structuring the the app
earlier was and and this is something
was really really nice is it's all
command line driven which is super cool
so you could write you know a shell
script or something or use something
like a yeoman style site bootstrapper
where you can say I want a new service
and it's called this and it will go and
create the directories and do the dotnet
news and the you know add reference and
all that kind of stuff because it's all
from command line yeah you know I can
spin that up you think I yeah so I can
basically script this so the the little
solution that I've got I spun up
completely from the command line so you
could script that you can automate it
which is really good in an organization
where you're trying to get people to
adopt new stuff is just remove the
friction so a little bit of a side story
yeah I suppose peaking to some people
from Amazon one day and they said look
the thing that really got them moving
around the whole service oriented
architecture thing was making it super
easy for somebody to spin up a new
service there was a little web app they
went to internally and they way and I
want a new service and I want to call it
X and it would go bang spit out the
stuff from convention and go this your
repo have fun and you can do that really
really nicely with dotnet core because
it all is all you know very command-line
driven so that's super cool or the other
thing you can do and this is what what
we're doing is sort of build up a
template get repo you can say I want to
clone this thing and you know all of
your common stuff is in there so we call
there's often black nobody got that Jack
so yeah anyway ci so started playing
with Jenkins you know which which I sort
of liked the idea of you know having a
Jenkins file in your in your orphan
black repo and it Just's been up and
work and then you know I started going
okay well do I build on this agent and
put it on is the thing that I'm building
a container and but I'm gonna I'll
probably run my CI thing in a container
and all of a sudden I've got darker and
darker and darker and I'm like and just
playing docker inception and it's like
no this is crazy
and so again I reached out to my network
for help and I sort of started talking
to a few people that were doing this
stuff you know like not on net but on
other platforms and and got some advice
and and one of the the things that I was
pushed towards was a tool called code
ship which is a posted yes
CI tool and I tried a few others and
coach it was the first one I had any
level of success with so so went with
that again that that took a little bit
of doing because all of their
documentation was like you have these
services and steps and they have all of
these services combined I'm set up where
you know like this is the service to do
your testing and this is a service to do
whatever and I just have one thing and I
just want to build it and none of the
documentation actually catered for that
so I'll quickly kind of talk a little
bit through how this works basically
you've got a couple of llamó files that
sit in your repo and you know I have
this service and this is the image and
it's got this local docker file and I
can specify environment variables to
push into that as well come back to that
one in a moment and then it's part of
your build you this was the problem with
code ship they sort of expected all
these steps to be there but I didn't
have a second step I just wanted to
build the thing I was having gotten as
far as pushing it anywhere but
essentially you know I've got a step
that pushes it to - I'm a CR which is
Amazon's I'm container registry
cial yeah so code ship basically set up
these Ammal files with stuff and to push
stuff into AWS they offer all these
little helper containers that do stuff
so they've got an image which is the AWS
ECR docker config generate generator so
if you use something like docker hub you
create a login for it and then you can
push containers to it ECI works a little
bit differently you use your AWS
credentials and it gives you a token and
you can use that token for 12 hours to
push through so they sort of bundled all
of that functionality into this into
this helper thing and they have a
command-line tool where when you create
a project and I won't go through this
whole process basically you create a
project in code ship and it will give
you an Aes key and you pull that down
and you use that to sign you AWS
keys and then you can push that
encrypted file you know which looks
something like that
you push that up and it will use that to
associate stuff and that took a whole
bunch of shenanigans to figure out and
understand because the documentation for
that and for my scenario were pretty
much non-existent but once we got there
I get a fairly nice output it's not
teamcity nice but it's pretty and I can
see my my output there so again I'm
missing the the this build had this many
tests and these ones passed and these
ones failed actually if it fails you
builds broken so yes if something does
go wrong you still find yourself digging
through logs to figure out what went
wrong but it's a fairly it'sit's the
simplest tool that I found to get a good
workflow so now I've got a build I can
build an image I can have someone else
build that image and then my next
problem is when hell am I going to put
it and that's then I open up a whole
bunch of stuff true Bonetti everyone's
talking about that amazon doesn't have
that yet I even looked into building my
own kubernetes cluster
and then I realized that was a
completely foolish thing to do so I
walked away from that I looked at Rancho
you know I know that that that Asia so I
had had some Cuban Eddie stuff but I
know I was a little bit behind you
talking a bunch of people and eventually
ended up with with a CES which is
Amazon's elastic container service and
it actually sort of it doesn't give you
all the features of kubernetes but it
was enough and it was the where I had
some success as anyone used to see us a
couple of people saying it works it
works but to do that I had to actually
build the infrastructure so I didn't
want to go into the AWS console and
clicky clicky clicky build all the
servers I wanted to be a little bit tum
more automated than that so at that
point I had to learn terraform again but
essentially very stripped down you know
I've got some some ec2 instances that
the thirties the ECS API controls I've
got a Postgres database on on RDS behind
that and then I've got you know a
bastion house and these things have all
those security groups and lock down so I
can SSH into the database if I really
really need to which I try not to do
because it makes you a bad person so
yeah that's that's essentially what the
easiest infrastructure looks like and
you have as many instances as you need
for scale and also if you want to roll
out a new version you sort of need some
spare instances to deploy them onto and
again if someone's interested I stole
and modified a lot for from this this
repo here guy named alex has a project
you if you google ECS terraform github
you'll find this and it was a pretty
good starting point for creating that
creating that that script and I'll show
you is anyone use tariffs on a handful
of people so basically it gives you a
DSL for specifying infrastructure as
code and so I can specify
specify an application that has an na lb
with some stuff there and I've got some
variables in this I can run it in
different environments and then I
specify my actual service on there and
then I can use and this is where you
jump into Amazon's JSON format to define
that service but basically it looks a
lot like docker compose or something
like that it's it sort of specifies all
of the the images and how they run and
what ports they can talk to and stuff
like that and I can pass environment
variables and if I want so basically
what terraform lets me do is on top of
this infrastructure definer service push
some JSON in and get it up and running
so yeah again if that's something that
interests you Google ACS terrifying
github and you'll you'll get into there
yeah so I showed the the terraform for
defining and out but basically my apps
at the moment look a bit like this I've
got cloud front in front and it's doing
some caching and some some SSL
termination and it's a DDoS protection
there's a really good talk if you go
looking for it one an engineer from from
slack and they talked about using cloud
front to sit in front of their API and
actually do that with like zero caching
they've got a casing completely turned
off but they found that they managed to
speed up connection latency like you
know in a measurable way they've far
more expensive tools and I do so I
haven't measured it basically by
offloading the SSL termination to
somewhere local so like if you hit slack
in Australia you're still hitting their
API instance you know in in the US but
your SSL is terminated here and the
handshake of that is actually a
noticeable thing so that's really nice
and AWS basically give you SSL
Certificates for free and install it's
just makes that super easy so that's a
really nice pattern to look into then I
talked to a load balancer which talks to
an engine X proxy which then talks to my
app container which has kestrel so
anyone berries too
yesterday buried urns talked he said in
2.2 that finally going to say yes you're
allowed to put Kestrel on the internet
and so I went it had a chat afterwards
and and he said like any one of these
things is enough for in terms of like
hiding Kestrel from the internet because
their concern is less about the like the
web serving but more about attacks
they're going to be holding connections
open and try to you know block sockets
and stuff like that then I had a chat to
to my friend good over here last night
and and they found something interesting
with Kestrel which is it has no request
queuing or rate limiting in it at all so
they found when they got hammered with a
lot of traffic which they do that AWS
helpfully scaled up to 5,000 instances
so that none of them were waiting ever
so so yeah from a security point of view
it's probably going to be okay soon
enough to remove some of these layers
but I suspect you probably want
something like that in front of it to
just manage that that extra stuff so
that was a I'm sorry you felt that pain
I was grateful for your learning so now
I'm sharing with everyone here
so yeah that's what that's what I Colo
say then it comes to deploying a new
version so there's a couple of ways of
doing this and the one we've basically
going with is a version that we want to
deploy we'll tag that with the
environment that we want to we want it
to go to and then we can say to ECS do a
new deployment and it will find the
latest image that matches that tag which
is a little bit different again from
what I'm used to saying like this
instant this environment has you know
version one point two point three seven
in it instead we're saying deploy the
latest that I've got tagged with staging
or production and just kick off a new
deployment that's how we're doing and I
don't love that a nicer way to do it
would be to specify the container image
version to do that but at the moment I
can say tag the image refresh your
deployment but to be able to say put
version one point three point seven in
that environment
requires me to go back and change my
terraform no you know and specified here
which then all of a sudden I'm mixing
kind of deployment concerns with the
infrastructure specification concerns
and and I'm not loving that so that
one's still that I've not you know it's
like what we've got is working really
well for us at the moment but I'm not
loving it another approach that I've
spoken to some people about that they're
doing and this is this is quite massive
that I've actually built their own
deployment database system so when they
have a build that succeeds they and this
is on AWS if they have a build that
succeeds and it pushes to ECR that will
kick off a lambda which sends that that
build information to a deployment
database that they've got which will
then kind of figure out what
configuration parameters and on-the-fly
generate that configuration Jason and
push it into into ecs which is pretty
big undertake in there and they're the
ones that have like 250 i'm environment
variables because they built their own
configuration management database as
well and it's possibly something like i
to like octopus could solve this because
they've essentially done the same things
like you've got your versions you've got
your environments you know what versions
make up a release in that environment
and what configuration variables but
yeah they're using that to then you know
build up that that big JSON file which
gets really big because of all their
environment variables and push it in so
that's another approach to it that
possibly is we scale we might need to
get two or maybe something like octopus
what will fill that gap again if
someone's solved that and really really
nicely I'd love to hear about it
yourself that one yep excellent your
mind your best friend so yeah that
that's kind of where we've got to with
that one
so I'm nearly out of time a couple of
fun little gotchas that I've hit along
the way one is ECS is sometimes
unreliable I think it has it has a bit
to do with sort of the underlying
infrastructure provisioning every now
and then you go do a deployment and
it'll go when I feel like it
you know it's just where the easier so
yeah another one that I hit was I had
specified to short a health check
timeout window and my health check hit
an API call that scan the database and I
hit a point where I had enough data in
the database and I had an indexed it
correctly because I was still wildly
iterating and all of a sudden my health
check wasn't returning in time so my
deployments would constantly fail and
and this happened one late Friday night
I mean I was probably a little bit
sleep-deprived and I just kind of had I
just nuked the box the auto scaling
group will pick it back up maybe the box
is broken and of course it was actually
my um health check timeouts were broken
and I brought everything down for a
couple of hours so that was a fun one
i tailed around all the time my life is
a cautionary tale I had some notes here
of some some other fun things that I've
hit along the way yeah just just ecs
being a little bit unpredictable
yeah deploying walking up taking too
long yeah making it frustrating about
the other thing that I've hit sort of
along the way and this is sort of the
differences across platforms is a lot of
what I do at the moment is hitting our
customer sites to sort of rein jobs off
their site and import them into our
system and something can be working
completely beautifully on my local
machine and then completely dies because
the SSL validation across the different
dotnet core runtimes is completely
different so the Linux SSL validation is
some a lot more strict than the Mac ones
which which is an argument for kind of
building and running and testing in the
container all the time but I do like
that sort of fast feedback look of being
able to work locally on my machine all
the time there's some there's some fun
gotchas some things that I'm doing next
better configuration management like I
said I still want to look at the
configure injector project and how to
bring it into this into this world and
and sort of have a nice day of
experience for configuration cuz I don't
really love what we're doing there I
hate having all my different
configuration JSON files in my repo so I
want to do something around better
secrets management so Amazon has a nice
solution to that I can say that box has
this permission it's this environment it
can go and hit key manager and get stuff
in so integrating the configure injector
stuff with key management is something I
want to do and I you know it's something
I need to do fairly soon to split up my
services but at the moment where my
stack looks like that as I split up
services I kind of do placate that stack
all the time and I don't want to do that
so something that is on my roadmap to
play with next years um it's something
called traffic and if anyone's seen
traffic no good has yeah it looks really
really nice as a sort of API proxy so I
have a traffic cluster you know behind
McLeod from could be a little like my
API and then underneath that I have the
services and traffic will manage routing
them all and eventually because in my
heart of hearts I'm a messaging guy
there'll be a message box underneath
there as well so yeah that's kind of my
road ahead it's nearly lunchtime thank
you so much for your patience with me
yeah like I said I'm not the expert on
this this is just sort of the the
journey that I've gone through and some
of the choices that I've had to make and
the struggle so by all means if you have
better ideas than me I would love to
hear them and maybe we can kind of share
them with the world but no look thank
you very much
[Applause]